oh it's that time again to talk about
the latest games in new releases first
up is the Last of Us remastered this
highly praised ps3 hit gets a graphics
boost and launches on to the ps4
experience the journey again in full
1080p and move right along to the
prequel DLC left behind multiplayer also
gets the new 1080p graphics update fans
will be happy to know that remastered
also features an in-game cinematic
commentary from the cast and creative
director put down the infected july
twenty ninth as they say no one's
perfect and you'll learn to love those
handicaps in robe legacy this
side-scrolling title debuted on PC and
has found its way to all of the current
PlayStation platforms in rogue legacy
each time you die your kids pick up
where you left off only they might be a
little different when child might be
nearsighted or another has a gas problem
where one could even be color blind are
you undecided which PlayStation version
to get no problem because when you buy
the PlayStation version you get to play
on them all cross save your game on the
Vita and pick up where you left off on
the ps4 far out make babies July 29th
for over six years we've waited biting
our nails banging our head against the
drywall six years we've waited some of
us got a taste but we felt teased but
now the wait is finally over I can't
believe to say this but on July 29
you'll be able to play firefall
this free-to-play MMO shooter is
officially coming out of beta and onto
your PC choose one of five classes grab
a Jump Jet and start leveling up that
battle frame team up with your buddies
for some PvE or maybe you don't even
have friends well you can start by
making some enemies in pvp fight with
fire July 29th it's time to get back in
your Titan pilots and wreck shop for
titanfall second DLC called frontiers
edge available for the Xbox one and PC
frontiers edge adds three new maps and a
new endgame trading system called black
market make credits from winning and use
the in-game currency system to purchase
burn card packs and Titan insignia
prepare for titanfall July thirty-first
for further details visit gamespot's new
releases page release dates are based on
me Taylor listings and are subject to
change see you next time and have a
wonderful day